You'd think by now scientists would have learned
everything there is to know about one oxygen
and two hydrogen atoms, H2O.
But we learn new things about water all the
time.
Really, we do.
Hey there, hydro-friends, Trace here for DNews!
Water is important for… well, every living
thing on earth; it is part of every single
cell in our bodies, and all plants and animals
need water to survive.
But despite its ubiquity, water is incredibly
unique.
It goes from solid to gas in a smaller temperature
range than many other compounds.
Plus, when you cool it down into ice, it expands
AND becomes less dense than its liquid form.
That doesn’t happen with most other substances!
You’d think by now, scientists would have
already learned everything there is to know
about this combination of one oxygen and two
hydrogen atoms — H2O.
But we learn new things about water all the
time!
For example, a study in the December 2016
Proceedings of the National Academy of Sciences
showed ice doesn’t melt the way you think
it does.
Instead of melting all at once, in a sort
of continuous process, it goes layer by layer...
The top layer is only 45 nanometers at its
thickest, or 1/1000 the thickness of a human
hair, and it stays liquid-like below 0 degrees
celsius...which is the reason ice is slippery!
In fact, this new study showed that it’s
liquid-like even at negative 38 degrees!
That’s...slick!
And while this study might be pretty “cool,”
another 2016 study from the International
Journal of Nanotechnology could be even more
awesome.
It found that water might actually have TWO
distinct liquid states.
You probably know that all matter exists in
one of five states — solid, liquid, gas,
sometimes plasma, and very rarely Bose-Einstein
condensate, where the atoms start to act like
waves.
But in this study, researchers found that
liquid water actually undergoes a change in
its properties — how it behaves — when
it is cooled from 60 degrees celsius to 40
degrees.
They’re calling this the “crossover temperature”.
In other words, even though water “looks”
identical just above and below this temperature
range, it has different properties, and thus,
is potentially two distinct types of liquid
water.
When water is cooled, it loses its ability
to store electrical energy — also called
its dielectric constant.
Researchers thought that this happened in
a linear fashion, but at the crossover temperature,
it gets a kink in this linear line.
This small change impacts other physical properties
of the liquid, like the speed of sound in
water and how it conducts heat.
Above 60C, liquid water’s chemical properties
look more like what we’d associate with
water vapor or steam.
Below that, the properties appear more ice-like.
And although the change is small, it may have
a dramatic effect on molecular systems.
The researchers looked at how proteins behave
in water at the crossover temperature, and
around the 60 degree mark, certain systems
of proteins go from being stable to unstable.
The researchers think that the physical changes
in water at this temperature may be impacting
the proteins directly.
With further research, this could help us
learn how certain diseases infect us.
The two states of liquid water could also
change how we work with microscopic systems,
like nanoparticles, which are sensitive to
this crossover temperature.
So, water is still kind of mysterious, and
there’s probably a lot more to learn about
it.
I mean, only recently have scientists learned
how it is even able to conduct electricity,
or the fact that forcing it through tiny tubes
changes it’s boiling and freezing points.
Even though it’s all around us and inside
of us, that’s no reason to take water for
granted.
We can’t do episodes like this without our
sponsors.
Thanks to Graze for sponsoring this episode
of DNews!
Graze makes snacking exciting by combining
wholesome ingredients with the flavors we
all love, to create over 100 nutritionist-approved
snacks.
Go to graze.com and enter promo code DNEWS
to get a free, sampler box delivered right
to your home or work!
All of these things we’re learning about
water are super cool, but what about hard
and soft water?
What’s the difference between those?
Check out this video about it, here.
Got any other water related questions?
Ask us in the comments, please subscribe,
and come back for more DNews.